we've already talked about some of the
most useful mods we want to see in
Skyrim for consoles but now let's take a
look at some of the most ridiculous odds
just a word of warning however you will
hear the infamous Skyrim line in this
video if it's still too soon for you
I'd recommend clicking out I don't need
to tell you how badass dragon shouts are
but if you ever wondered what happens
when the dragon born farts probably not
but I have in moderate twiggy Skyrim has
fulfilled my weird sick fantasies
turns out farts and shouts are basically
interchangeable this mod changes around
and adds a few new animations so when
you do a shout it looks like it's coming
from your butt I'm not sure if diet has
anything to do with the potency of these
shouts but I'd say they're pretty deadly
as is there are two kinds of people in
this world the kind that replaced their
dragons with Thomas the Tank Engine and
the kind that replaces their dragons
with Macho Man Randy Savage there's only
one correct answer and that is macho man
Macho Man Randy Savage is the stuff of
nightmares apart from his hideously
disfigured body he yells things like the
Macho Man Randy Savage unbalanced
doesn't me oh wait sorry we're talking
about Skyrim right yeah this month's
pretty disturbing too
one of the most disturbing I've seen
until I saw this crimes against nature
is exactly what it sounds like it adds a
number of races including idea born dog
mayor dovabear and uh sanic so I guess
if you hate yourself enough you can play
Skyrim is one of the biggest crimes
against nature ever created fortunately
the design is a little off so it's not
as bad as it could be right this mod
also adds this so yeah anything come on
Princess
sure in fact if we want to make Skyrim
really weird let's hope all of
fancy-pants mods will come to console
don't you King say it don't you from
exam I used to be an adventurer then I
took an arrow with me and I took an
arrow and I'm near I used to be an
octave an arrow in the knee best mod
ever 10 out of 10
basically chickens that are packed to
the feathers with dynamite there really
isn't much to say about this mod other
than that it's been a classic of one of
our favorite shows on gamespot top 5
Skyrim mods there's no shortage of
follower mods on Skyrim but let's turn
our attention to Bruce hammer shall we
Bruce is a fully voiced follower
designed to belittle you as much as he
can as you help him bring trains into
the world of Skyrim or something like
that he's got a lot of weird moves lots
of interesting catchphrases and he's
really into trains this mod also adds a
very low unfriendly quest line and it
probably goes well with that Thomas the
Tank Engine mod which I mentioned
earlier I know I've missed a lot of
hilarious mods to let me know some of
your favorites in the comments below or
you can let me know on twitter at jacob
deck if you enjoyed this video make sure
to LIKE and subscribe until next time